So we're looking at clips from Trump's corona
virus press briefing yesterday.
We're doing it in short clips instead of one
big review, because I want to make sure that
each of these stories sort of gets its own
time up because it was a really weird press
briefing.
So Trump said completely randomly to a Bloomberg
or to Bloomberg reporter Mario Parker, that
he looks like Michael Bloomberg.
Now, what's really odd about this is that
Mario Parker is black and looks nothing like
it.
Nearly 80 year old Jewish man named Michael
Bloomberg.
Take a look at this clip.
Bloomberg, just a Bloomberg.
Mr. President, I think it's an extension of
supplemental unemployment aid.
If the deal has to go to Congress isn't completed
by the end of this week, what what does anybody
make of this Telles that tells the I think
this is the one black guy in the room tells
the one black guy in the room.
You look like Michael Bloomberg.
Why does.
Is this what Donald Trump thinks counts as
some kind of joke?
Like, is this humor of some kind?
Is this meant to be clever?
I don't even really get what he's going for.
Does Trump think, you know, one idea I had
was.
Does Trump think this is a way to signal that
you're not racist?
Like you, he's saying he's colorblind in a
sense.
You tell a black guy he looks like a white
guy.
I guess that means that Trump really is colorblind.
He doesn't see color and he just sees people
as people.
But it's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
I was laughing.
Someone tweeted me.
You know, David, this should have been a question
on Trump's much famed cognitive tests that
cognitive tests that Trump claims has 35 questions,
even though it has like 12, that Trump says
the last few questions over very, very difficult
questions that Trump says neither Joe Biden
nor Fox News host Chris Wallace could successfully
could score as high as Donald Trump did.
They should have put up a picture of a black
reporter and said, does this man look like
Michael Bloomberg and see if Donald Trump
passes the test.
Really, really bizarre stuff.
And I don't know if we chalk this up to or
consider this a part of Donald Trump's.
A cognitive question marks.
Is this Trump trying to be funny?
Is this I mean, is it thinly veiled racism
of some kind, like rather.
I don't even understand this.
And I need.
Excuse me.
I need your help actually trying to figure
it out.
But needless to say, the idea of bringing
back these press briefings, Kellyanne Conway
said, I think it was two weeks ago.
The reason Trump's approval is down is he's
no longer doing corona virus press briefings.
And very shortly thereafter, Donald Trump
decided to bring them back.
The idea being it would help his approval
rating by next week.
We'll have a sense of whether Trump's approval
rating is reversing course and improving.
What seemed clear to me early on was these
press briefings were actually the cause of
low approval ratings.
And you might remember that the press briefings
were abruptly stopped when Donald Trump wondered
aloud about what about injecting isopropyl
alcohol or bleach into the body as a sort
of cleaning for corona virus.
Seems to me the problem wasn't that there
was an incredible demand for press briefings.
And after the break, we're going to talk about
Donald Trump doubling down in his support
of a doctor who believes hydroxy chloroquine
works to prevent Corona virus or to treat
Corona virus, who believes that if you have
sex with a demon, it can cause gynecological
issues?
Who believes you don't need to wear a mask?
Who believes that there is already a cure
for a corona virus?
And who believes that there is a plan?
I hope you're sitting down to develop a vaccine
that will make you immune from becoming religious.
OK, that's after this short break.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David Pakman.